الصين من جانبها طلبت ببذل مزيد من الجهود
لضمان امندات الطاقه العالميه
الثانيه
في مجال الطاقه يقوم على الاحترام
والمنفعه المتبادلين
بخصوص
الروسي ما الذي قالته المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الصينيه بخصوص ذلك
نعم مريم ايه لم تزد المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه عما ذكرتم في الخبر وقالت ان
العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه في مجال الطاقه
هي مستقره ويعني تلتزم كل من البلدين
بالاحترام
المتبادل بينهما ولا ننسى ان هذه العلاقه
او شحنات الطاقه النفط بين روسيا والصين
استمرت على الرغم من العقوبات التي فرضت
فرضها لاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
خلال الاشهر الماضيه وكما نعلم ان هناك
شحنات من الطاقه من النفط الروسي وصلت الى
الصين بالفعل خلال الاشهر الماضيه لدرجه
ان احد همم هذه الفترات او احدى هذه تلك
الشحنات فقط
الشحنات التي تستقبلها الصين من السعوديه
التي كانت تعتبر المصدر الاول للصين من
النفط اذا الصين يعني لا تزال همم لا تخفي
هذا الموضوع وانها لا تزال تستورد النفط
الروسي ايضا تستغل الصين هذه الفتره
والحرب الاوكرانيه والعقوبات على روسيا
همم من ناحيه الاسعار فهناك عقود همم بين
الصين وروسيا في مجال تصدير النفط الروسي
الى الصين همم وقعت خلال الفتره الماضيه
باسعار منافسه والصين همم تستغل هذه
الفتره
لكسب المزيد من هذه من من الطاقه همم
الروسيه همم الصين ايضا تنظر الى مثل تلك
العقوبات الاوروبيه على النفط الروسي
بانها تضر
بعمليه توريد النفط وحركه النفط العالميه
وبالتالي همم
ستزيد من الاسعار
ضرب العديد من البلدان وطالبت بان لا يكون
مثل هذه العقوبات في همم المستقبل بحيث لا
تضر على حركه امتداد النفط نعم مريم يعني
عمليه كيف تتعامل الصين مع قرار الاوروبي
اذا دخل حي التنفيذ عام يعني
واثرت اوروبا على ان يتم التزامه به
نعم عبد الصمد من خلال همم ما قالته
المتحدثه يعني بين السطور عندما قالت همم
تطلب من الجميع الالتزام همم يعني همم
توفير الظروف المناسبه لحركه النفط
الدوليه بذلك ربما تعني بانها سوف يعني
ستستمر الصين لن توقف وارداتها من روسيا
في الوقت الحالي كون هناك كما ذكرت انفا
هناك عقود موقعه بين الصين وروسيا ولا شك
بان الصين سوف تستمر في همم استيراد النفط
من روسيا كونها همم قالت بان العلاقات
الصينيه همم الروسيه همم يعني تتسم بهمم
همم
المنفعه المتبادله للجانبين وتعني بهذه ان
الصين تحتاج الى النفط الروسي وايضا روسيا
تحتاج الى تصدير النفط الى الصين في في
مثل هذه الظروف التي تمارس عليها
العقوبات من الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات
المتحده
مدير مكتبنا في بيت جين